thank you
[Music]
guys play uh Grand Theft Auto oh yeah I
love it I loved Grand Theft but the
video game not real life
GTA online was so [ __ ] sick for a
while like a couple months in like 2015
I was like damn this is pretty fun yeah
I feel like a lot of people
um that aren't into gaming fail to grasp
how insane GTA it's so the OG metaverse
well not even in terms of like yeah
exactly not even terms of like the that
but just how much of a Powerhouse Money
Maker it is like people just don't get
the scale they made a billion on the
launch it's the micro transactions where
you like buy like clothes and [ __ ] they
make like hundreds of millions of
dollars off that [ __ ] yeah I'll give you
guys the hard figures in a bit it's it's
pretty crazy but the long term some news
came out uh recently that in the early
2000s there was a an offer to create GTA
the movie
and why they were gonna have Eminem
starring it whoa yeah but there's lots
of Eminem by the way yeah but then
Rockstar turned it down why Rockstar
said no thanks
wow and that's the thing a lot of people
who aren't into gaming are like they're
idiots for that why didn't they take
this movie down I love it Eminem in it
why didn't they do that and uh you start
to see these comments in your life
wow really they really don't know
um so here's some GTA facts for those of
uh you out there that might be
unfamiliar so uh
now you can also be intimidated with it
like the rest of us it's uh it took 256
million to make GTA 5. that's the final
number of the budget within the first 24
hours of release it made 800 million
first 24 hours wow last year alone this
game came out in 2013 By the way there's
a game from 23rd still holds up almost
10 years that's a last year it's still
made a billion dollars in online
transaction well we also came up with
like the casino like they keep adding
[ __ ] new skins you know improvements to
the online yeah he's doing it for them
yeah I haven't played an age shark card
shark cards are like yeah it's like the
in-game money in-game currency yeah I
saw people like make money off building
servers and then they sell it and they
populate it to like online players
that's uh yeah those are the uh the role
play servers yeah
you could get goals wait those are lame
or what yeah why well I just remember
please break these dude role players are
[ __ ] lame yeah that's a hundred
thousand percent it's LARP within a lot
of bases yeah yeah like my brother
um my little brother Kenny he used to
play this game do you remember Kyle
katarn the Jedi Knight series with the
PC game so he would he would role play
in this game like on a role play server
as a Jedi in training and like he had a
[ __ ] Jedi Master [ __ ] it was kind of
like
it was kind of whack you know so what
would he do like well they would walk in
the temple but like if you hold down a
certain key you don't run you walk and
so they would like Trail together reach
you know respectfully walking the video
games is the worst it's weird you don't
want to get to some place yeah it takes
too long it's [ __ ] weird so all these
weirdos like walking around the temple
and I I'm like I just see my little
brother he's like seven years younger
than me walking around a temple and like
you know then getting down Indian style
and [ __ ] like like meditation Kenny
yeah Kenny
and I'm like what the [ __ ] are you
absolutely doing and he's like nothing
nothing and I'm like I'm like what is
this what is this and then my brother
Nate told me that he's in he's he's in a
Jedi group and like they're role-playing
together and [ __ ] and I love it I love
it
it was the most devastating thing I
think I've ever seen as a big brother
but if they were role playing on GTA
that's a whole different story that's
where you're like friends are going to
the [ __ ] strip club you know like
it's a different kind of loser in the
GTA the thing that you're asking about
which is the GTA RP servers those you
have your um you're basically policed by
the server leader to act like the role
that you are so let's say you play the
server right in your uh cop right yeah
you have to actually act like a cop you
gotta actually pull people over you got
to do cop [ __ ] you have to speak like a
cop and you can't break character if you
break character you get deleted from the
server no trolls allowed so whatever
your job is that you take on and there's
a list like whatever you choose to do
even if you want to buy a car you're
buying it from another real guy and
you're brokering a deal on the street
and everything you can't just like hit
them and take it you gotta like have
real conduct like that's not GTA I know
it's like my sister playing GTA she used
to follow like the traffic signs and
[ __ ]
on the stop lights yes it's a different
point I have a very lame family by the
way very little does it hit anybody it
doesn't hit people they sound very
recording that's what else she's got
[Laughter]
so the crazy thing is uh in 2019 GTA
online just just online was making 5
million a day whoa per day so when you
compare that with let's say Eminem's
highest grossing movie which is of
course Eight Mile Eight Mile Eight Mile
to this date since release made 242
million which is of course really great
but also GTA doesn't really need to do
that yeah there's probably a bigger
benefit the soundtrack for me must have
made a bunch too but GTA is still
[ __ ] it up yeah hey we don't want to
[ __ ] with our brand like because if the
movie's a disaster it could [ __ ] with it
exactly yeah how do you make that good
you know well the thing is it's probably
more beneficial for all parties if
Eminem was just a character in GTA I
mean that's what that's what I was gonna
say because like they had Jonah Hill
they had like Ludacris what's it Jonah
Hill though that was like the kid from
Pete and Pete he just looks like
I thought they use Jonah Hill it's just
Seth Rogen it was her thing they were
like why does that guy look so much like
Jonah Hill it sounded like him
they're getting away with like sort of
sound alike he's like the sun right
because GTA is also notoriously known
for not paying the actors enough because
they're parroting at them too exactly
they're really getting away with like
and they have really really great people
that are underrated in Hollywood so like
the actors they get playing the mains
should be Steve moffatt or whatever his
name is the guy who was Trevor yes
exactly yeah but like you look at GTA
right like the story is obviously the is
is the underpinning of the whole game
like when you watch it and you you go
through it you're like oh I'm playing a
20-hour movie pretty much it is a little
distracting when let's say Dr Dre shows
up and it's really him yeah it's a
little bit weird I like it better when
there's people that I don't know in real
life and they really make the character
believable yeah you know although the
movie is hard San Andreas though having
Samuel Jackson as officer 10 Penny
though was right on the market [ __ ] was
dope he's good in everything he can for
some reason it just works and everything
because he's already in everything yeah
exactly yeah yeah right but then they do
they do get a lot of uh I guess Flack
from past people that have worked with
them that are like dude I can't believe
this thing makes this much money I'm
getting paid that much yeah yeah
because yeah no one gets royalties for
that [ __ ] like that no way so I don't
have time to play games no more but I
like walkthroughs right like yeah Do It
um one thing I did during the pandemic
was I spent like an hour through each
era of GTA
one hour just from each one
just one hour I know walkthroughs I
would just kind of like my first
introduction was the top down View yeah
and then yeah GTA and then the next one
was the second version of that but they
had the these weird gangs like the
Yakuza and then the the cult remember
that one the Hayabusa Clinton or
whatever yeah number two yeah the number
two and then the first one that was like
first person or that third person view
the the first GTA that came out GTA
three that's the one that was like oh
[ __ ] with Claude yeah that was really
cool 3D dude it was unbelievable that
blew my blew my mind at the back of my
head and then by City came out my city
oh that was so cool how about they're
coming back to Vice City yeah the sixth
one that's gonna be wild because it's
like VI yeah oh yeah that's really good
when does that come out I don't know we
should we should hop on a [ __ ] server
where I run a store in GTA try to rob
you we do this right here in GTA do this
this would be sick I do wish like if you
guys ever played GTA I wish you'd play
my tracks because I have made over a
hundred GTA custom tracks really in the
in the you could listen to it that's
like a guilty pleasure about it like I
just created a bunch of Disguise
that nobody else does race tracks yeah
kind of but it's all right let's do it
then let's let's [ __ ] do it I'll get
it I'll get the [ __ ] game and
JK gaming starts up that would be one of
the funnest things we have a JK gamer we
got to find the password for
I just love how ready to go that sounds
when GTA can't step away when the online
game came out I did I did GTA trolling
where I I was role-playing as a cop and
I was like [ __ ] around with people it
was really fun the game was fun so one
one of the biggest uh craziest things on
GTA online servers nowadays and kind of
has been for a while if you're playing
on PC uh chances are you get to end up
in a server with at least two or three
hackers and by hackers I mean you pay uh
there's a lot of companies that make
these trainers that you can open up at
the same time you're playing the game so
you'll open up this exterior window and
it gives you the [ __ ] powers of a God
in the game that you just do things to
troll the [ __ ] out of the whole place
like you could start making it look like
it's strobe lighting between winter and
summer for everyone playing and they're
just like [ __ ] this or you can like put
people in cages set them on fire you can
you can literally close their GTA from
their Microsoft Windows like you can do
anything it's hilarious I did that for a
little bit so that was funny because we
wanted to uh we play like a big group of
like 10 people and I wanted to like help
protect us against those guys one thing
you can do is also be a hacker and you
basically turn on something that makes
everyone hack proof in your party white
hat yeah I was trying to be a white hat
but at the same time you get a little
tempted with some of those options
you're a little tempted you know that's
sick yeah what are some stuff that
because I know you told stories about
some [ __ ] you used to do bro yeah first
of all I have a Batmobile in that game
which is pretty crazy that's cool
um no I remember this little kid was
like [ __ ] he kept he killed me one
time it's all he had to do was kill me
one time and then I was basically like
okay the remainder of my day will be
killing this
and he's like this little brisket and he
was and he was he was him and his
friends were like you could tell he was
playing with his friend and like they're
like in a car together and they enjoyed
drive-by shooting me or whatever when I
was walking out of the gun store
so then I get in my car and I proceed
and I have a helicopter that I can call
like whenever I want everyone has this
but I'm just saying like it's pretty
amazing for me as like as a player and
so I was like you know getting in my
helicopter I would Kamikaze directly
onto the top of their car and just blow
us all up and I was constantly coming at
the raw angles my Batmobile appears from
nowhere [ __ ] ramming them into the
wall constantly constantly constantly
they didn't stand a chance because we
didn't know where they were [ __ ] was
so funny because I won't give up I will
literally not quit until you leave the
server in frustration that's what they
ended up having to do I'm gonna play
with Steve dude I want to hang out with
Steve dude you got to play Pirate game
we got to play Grand Theft Auto
uh and Modern Warfare let's do it let's
do it we've got a lot of things on my
cue we gotta start this channel find the
passwords no we should just play and
then we'll see if the channel deserves
it